[Music]
this morning in our school matters
series we are looking at why fewer men
are going to college than women only
about 4 in 10 college students are men
and that is a record low according to
the wall street journal colleges and
universities have lost one and a half
million students over the past five
years and men make up 71 percent of that
decline this gender gap is not new but
it's been widening for nearly half a
century we spoke with marcus pickens
who's from englewood california about
why he left college
i was a decent student in high school i
wasn't
the best student but i also didn't
necessarily try my best i faced academic
struggles so the first thing i noticed
when i got into
college was that i was underprepared to
take college level mathematics i was
having significant financial problems so
i ended up having to work seven days a
week i had a realization that
i'm not about to let school define who
who i am you know so i started planning
a business i was like you know what if
my dad can do it
with an 11th grade education and make
his business successful enough to
purchase a home you know then what's
stopping me
ron lieber is the author of the price
you pay for college and he joins us now
few people know more than you about this
subject
so help us understand why have men been
dropping out in essence for almost 50
years yeah so we have a historical issue
that starts with the fact that we send
18 year olds to college in first place
it's not at all clear that that's the
optimal time to go now we've got a
decade or two of history of student loan
debt that people have that on the brain
and then you get to a pandemic right and
people are looking to value right the
classes are online you may not be able
to meet your friends and if you've got
an opportunity in the marketplace where
there are a lot of jobs going wanting
and their jobs traditionally
that men have taken and they may be
higher paid jobs
it sort of sounds to start to seem like
a rational decision to not go to college
right away yeah now college may not be
the best option for everyone but what
other alternatives should people
consider well this is part of our
challenge as a society right we don't
necessarily value the high school to
work pipeline as much as we write good
right we don't have the right apprentice
programs we don't have the right support
systems we may not be supporting
community colleges that may offer trade
programs as much as we might and so we
don't value it quite in the same way and
we probably ought to do better at that
were you saying ron that 18 is not the
right age to go to college is that what
you're saying yeah i mean many many
decades ago we just decided that that's
the way that it ought to be but that was
before you know a lot of the best
science on adolescent psychology and
brain development discovered that you
know brains are not that fully formed
until maybe your early 20s or mid-20s so
we're spending all this money on college
for people who may not be ready and men
young men um don't come along as quickly
as young women do on app i do that's
true but what would you do when you
graduate from high school because most
people many people can't afford not to
go to college sure in terms of getting
your career going yeah so what we're not
talking about here is the sort of
classic gap year as it's come to be
conceived a sort of rich person's
layabout um there can be apprentice
programs there can be military service
there can be non-military national
service there can be a year of volunteer
work there can be all sorts of jobs
where you can go to find your passion or
just rule something out because if you
can figure out something that you don't
want to do in the world that you don't
want to study and raise money on later
you've accomplished something very
important this really changes the
college experience for kids currently at
school kids on their way to school
because if you've got 60 women on campus
40 percent men that's an imbalance right
are schools gonna have to start favoring
men as weird as that sounds to bring
them in
in a few schools that's already
happening right and if you are an
administrator at one of those schools
you have to sort of think about it right
because if you're trying to correct the
gender imbalance and there's a certain
percentage of the population that wants
to go to a 50 50 school it's not a good
look to be 60 40 right so you may need
to put your thumb on the scale for men
in certain instances at some schools now
you can find data that supports
investing in college which helps you
with a degree and then going into the
workforce but then you can find data
that shows you can go right into the
workforce out of high school what do you
think is the best option
well much depends on what your interest
and aptitude might be for college right
not everybody wants to spend four years
in the classroom and there are people
who are
good with coding or who are good with
their hands um who could find a more
worthwhile and satisfying career by
going straight into the workplace yeah
by the way national service military or
not at age 18 would be something this
country could benefit from a lot of
people believe that it's a conversation
that comes up every now and then could
be a solution you're right about that
ron lieber thank you so much for joining
us
we will be right back